avec de nouveaux jeux et de nouveaux
espaces la ludothèque jeux des îles de
montigny le bretonneux reprend du
service pour les enfants ce qu'on va se
connecter avec cette espace tel pour la
réaménager ses favoris de la relation
parent enfant pour que les parents
jouent vraiment avec leurs enfants ils
n'ont pas une fois d'endroits où les
enfants se débrouillerait donc ça c'est
vraiment la partie nouveauté de cette
année
ah oui j'aime beaucoup ce qu'il ya plein
de jeux à disposition du coup il ya plus
de jeu qu'à la maison
donc ça leur plaît en plus de cet espace
éveil pour les six mois à trois ans la
ludothèque bénéficie d'une grande salle
supplémentaire pour favoriser de
nouvelles animations comme les ateliers
d'initiation à la robotique
j'ai fait un circuit un petit robot qui
va suivre les circuits
et il ya des codes de couleurs il
fallait rénover cette ludothèque
tout simplement parce que c'est un
équipement qui avait 30 ans 30 ans dont
com ou 30 ans d'une part l'équipement
avait beaucoup vieilli et puis de
l'autre les besoins ont aussi évolué
l'accès est libre du mardi au samedi
pour les adhérents ils peuvent même
emprunter des jeux pour un euro
[Musique]